تنظيف صيني نحو تخفيف قيود الاغلاق التي
فرضت بسبب انتشار لافته لفيروس كورونا فقد
شهدت مدن صينيه عده من بينها العاصمه بكين
واشنغاي عوده حركه القطارات واستئناف
الدراسه فيما اعلنت السلطات تخفيفه
متطلبات الحجر الصحي ولقد سياسه صفر كوفيد
الصارمه التي تنتهجها السلطات الصينيه
انتقادات غربيه واسعه خصوصا من قبل منظمه
الصحه العالميه
الثانيه
وتحاول حقا الان تعديل التدبير السيطره
على هذا الفيروس وذلك مع احترامي خصوصيات
الاشخاص وحياتهم الشخصيه
اجرى الرئيس الصيني
محادثات في العاصمه بكين مع رئيس المجلس
الاوروبي شارد ميشال وبسبب سياسه الصين
الصارمه ضد الفيروس زار ميشال العاصمه
الصينيه ليوم واحد وتحرك في عزه داخل
دائره مغلقه وهي اول زياره يقوم بها زعيم
اوروبي الى بكين بسبب اقرار حاله الطوارئ
الخاصه بالوباء قد انتهت لكننا لم نصل بعد
اليها هناك فجوات في المراقبه ولكن
الاختبار والتلقيح مستمران بهدف مجابه
احتمال ظهور فيروس جديد مثير للقلق الحلقه
سياسه الصين في مكافحه 19 الضرر باقتصادها
واثرت على كل القطاعات تقريبا مثل استهلاك
المحلي وانتاج المصانع وحتى السلاسل
التوريد العالميه وتسببت في ضغوط نفسيه
شديده لمئات الملايين من الناس واشعلت
الغضب الشعبي وافرزت احتجاجات عامه